I have for you today one of the most
cringe inducing interviews I've seen in
my time doing this type of thing in
online media in broadcast media so this
apparently I have to back up a little
bit
Candice Owens Candice Owens is this sir
fabricated black conservative hero very
well funded she has quickly become a
darling of the pro-trump
right and she I guess has a new show the
show is part of the outrageously
right-wing Prager University on YouTube
connected with outrageous right winger
Dennis Prager so I guess she has a show
there now I don't know how new it is
I've never seen it before I think it's
pretty new yesterday I saw the first
episode of my life and one of these
first episodes contains an interview
with cultural critic Dave Rubin okay the
interview is that case study in
sophistry
and faux intellectualism but I don't
even really want to call it that it's
not even phone intellectualism no one
would actually mistake it for that it's
more like faux faux intellectualism it's
faux intellectualism that even fails to
be that if you can imagine and it was
rife with just a panoply of were not not
even just bad ideas but obviously dumb
ideas widely debunked ideas and I felt
the cringe like the hairs on my arms
went up because my body physically could
not tolerate the meaningless and vapid
nature of this discussion all frame does
reasonable people talking about ideas
and pointing out how terrible and off
the rails everybody else is including of
course primarily the American left um
this is an hour long or an hour and five
or ten minutes long I don't know that I
would recommend that you watch it all if
you do you can put it on to X speed on
YouTube and get through the bulk of it
in like 25 minutes without including the
first and last minutes which was sort of
like a a wind up and a wind down where
Dave Rubin and Candace Owens just throw
bouquets at each other I'm
gonna include any of that here today so
I'm just skipping around this is not a
comprehensive tour of the interview you
can randomly drop in at any point during
this thing and you're gonna find a
treasure trove of absurdity but let's
start with this moment sort of early in
the interview where Candace Owens tells
Dave Rubin that she's going to confront
him and call him out and of course this
is meant to show that they're not scared
of disagreement everyone can
respectfully disagree and get along and
no one gets offended except what she
wants to call him out about is that he's
simply too smart to be a classical
liberal he's too smart to have the word
liberal associated with him at all even
though classical liberalism is very
right-wing so she wants to call him out
Wow
what courage it took from Candace Owens
take a look I'm gonna call you out on
something yes saying that you're a
classical liberal it's not physically
nauseous okay the whole world knows
there's just no way you're too practical
you're too smart and you're not gonna
sleep well that's I'm still learning
we've watched your stuff okay you've
spoken to so many people you have an
in-depth knowledge of things that you've
done stuff on on even it's like a Daleks
I just you're like a wealth of knowledge
and yet you insist on calling yourself a
classical liberal and it's cheap and
it's ending today well first off I want
to thank you for putting vodka in here
help this portion of the conversation
okay so look I am a classical liberal
and I would argue if we say if we sit
here long enough I can get you to admit
that you're a classical liberal too this
is III mean it's difficult to watch it's
really difficult to watch you're just
too smart for being anything with the
word liberal in it of course totally
ignorant of the fact that small-l
liberalism is not progressivism in the
sort of modern American context and
Rubin is right he probably could
convince her that she's a classical
liberalism classical liberal because
classical liberalism is just a semantic
game for conservatism or a particular
brand of it we did a long expose about
it I don't need to get into it but
conservatives now are play
this sort of semantic game with
classical liberalism okay let's go to
another point where Candis Owens defends
Alex Jones now this is this is just
amazing recently she said Hitler's
problem was going beyond Germany with
his goals she skipped over the killing
of six million Jews if Hitler had simply
remained a nationalist versus becoming a
globalist wrong use of the word
globalist but it doesn't matter then
that would have been a whole other thing
and Hitler would have been much more
reasonable he or she is defending Alex
Jones if there's one thing that I've
learned and I'm constantly growing and
learning it's just that I actually
really have a problem with the way that
social media has banned certain people
like I again I've probably watched ten
minutes of the Alex Jones Show of info
wars of his show and it was the ten
minutes I was on it when I first started
right um and I sat next to him and to be
honest he kind of is like a WWE style
like screaming at the bike and but
nothing that he said or at least why I
was sitting there and again I I'm
ignorant I could be completing ignorance
here with something that is worthy of
being banned from every platform and
they're also banning people in the ways
in the ways they make income and I can't
just PayPal and you can't you strike and
my whole perspective is that today you
tomorrow me understand what she's saying
I've never seen any Alex Jones except
for the ten minutes when he was
interviewing me and during those ten
minutes he didn't say anything that was
ban worthy so therefore it's wrong for
him to be banned from any platforms what
about the persistent peddling of
conspiracy theories leading to bleed 'el
action against them what about the
multiple large-scale bullying campaigns
of individuals breaking every element of
the terms and conditions of private
companies who I thought Candice would
support having their rights as private
companies to decide who's on their
platform and who isn't respected or does
she think that that's not to be
respected and it's so brilliant I might
be ignorant but in the ten minutes I was
on the Alex Jones Show which she claims
are the only ten minutes she's ever seen
she didn't see anything that justified a
ban of Alex Jones on any platform sounds
like she's super well placed to be the
person deciding what Alex Platt
what platforms should be doing with Alex
Jones right I mean this is just idiocy
at the highest level then they go into
sort of race and IQ stuff again with
this totally bogus notion that the left
doesn't want to talk about so-called
biological realities it's all about
being real and a realist and they start
sort of dancing around it take a look
speaking of feminism no feminism and
trends to be like how's that gonna kind
of go in together because I thought
feminism classic feminism we want
equality with men and we've carved out
all these spaces for us and in sports
and now all of a sudden men can talk
about the pages or he can step into what
we're doing and beat us at everything
biologically right they can do that I
don't want men abusing women unless
they're wrestling them and saying thank
you so cold yeah and it's insane to me
that this is open this is okay this is
even a debate or discussion well this is
I mean but this is what they do they
stake out crazy positions and then they
make you negotiate backwards so like
look the worst player in the NBA the
worst male professional basketball
player would be the MVP of the WNBA
that's exactly that's just true I don't
take some great pleasure in saying yeah
I remember there was this woman when the
so this is straw Manning on multiple
levels first of all they're mostly
talking about issues that number one
aren't really that important like okay
I agree that there is a reasonable
position to take that if you were born
biologically male does it make sense for
you to compete in wrestling against
individuals born biologically female
probably not it's not transphobic but
it's also not a big issue it's not a
significantly important issue in our
culture it doesn't connect to listen if
people born biologically men a male can
wrestle women then the next thing you
know I don't even know right I mean the
this is straw Manning as in that in the
sense that these are not even really the
most important issues but it's also
straw Manning in that if you want to
talk about equality between men and
women it's not about people born
biologically male who get to wrestle
against women right that's not that
destroy feminism this is not something
that the left is even consumed with many
people don't think if you're born
biologically male people on the left you
should be able to wrestle women and it's
just really a not not a major issue if
you're talking about chess for example
where the division between men and women
is more because there are more male
grandmasters and you want to incentivize
women to participate and if they are
competing in a group that is women when
we've talked about this right but if
you're born biologically male and you
you are a trans woman and you want to
participate in women's chess who care I
mean like of course that's completely
fine this is just not the hill on which
anyone is holding this debate and
they're pretending that that's the case
and then they get into this biological
reality sparse that the left just
doesn't want to talk about biological
realities well when I remember in the
WNBA started there was this woman
Cynthia Cooper who played on the Houston
and I think they were the Houston Comets
and she was awesome
she was awesome but I remember thinking
she would be a scrub in the NBA you know
you mean clay because she was still
small women generally are smaller she
wasn't really that fast compared to the
way a fast man is these are these are
just biological realities and they don't
want us to be able to talk about
biological realities i I don't like
seeing those pictures when I see a
transact lete so a male to female trans
athlete joking a woman and then I see
the women on the left and the women's
March and and that through the feminists
defending that because they've created
this intersectional pyramid where now
trans is sort of above female and Islam
is above that and this is about that and
this is about that this is just so
stupid right who could watch this and
say you know what that's really
insightful and interesting this is a
clinic on straw Manning they've set up
and agreed upon false pillars of
feminism and trans rights and now
they're in their echo chamber agreeing
about how bad it is that the left
doesn't want to talk about this stuff
they've set the parameters of the debate
in a fraudulent way this is not the real
debate that is happening and then they
critique it this is how an echo chamber
and you know but by the way the whole
they don't want to talk about biological
realities there is no biological reality
that the left in total doesn't want to
talk about you can find individuals who
have views that are wacky and there are
plenty of individuals on the right that
have wacky views usually when they talk
about biological realities they
eventually get to race an IQ and we know
the biological realities there they are
not the realities of the so-called race
realists and it's not that the left
isn't allowing a conversation about it
that it's been widely researched we're
bored by it at this point insisting that
black people are dumber because they are
black on the basis of IQ tests it's old
news it's boring and you're not someone
who is shutting down debate because
you're sick of the old tired debunked
debate so that's a little bit of the
show it's stunning that I think in some
conservative circles what you just saw
counts as like nuanced discussion if you
were to parody such an interview if you
were to parody an interview between
candace owens and dave rubin it would be
identical I mean it's indistinguishable
from a parody of itself and it also
important to mention they talk about the
free market of ideas this is not the
free market because these are really
well-funded operations Prager you which
is extraordinarily well funded brought
in Candace Owens and now she's in this
position whereas wow she's really this
is the free market it's not she was
forced upon people by organizations like
turning-point USA and Prager you and
they don't even yeah they're not even
subscribing to the principles they claim
to let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show